Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 35. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie. In der wir uns mit allen erdenklichen Aspekten der Wissenschaft und auch der Wissenschaftskommunikation auseinandersetzen. Wissenschaftskommunikation war hier schon ein paar Mal ein Thema, und so soll es auch heute wieder sein. Und zwar wollen wir heute genau genommen gleich über zwei verschiedene Arten der Wissenschaftskommunikation sprechen, aber in gewisser Hinsicht haben die dann auch wieder viel gemeinsam. Und wenn es nur die Person ist, mit der wir das jetzt hier zusammenführen und ich begrüße dafür erst mal Julia Offer, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Julia, du bist selber Wissenschaftlerin, Biologin?
Ja richtig.
Schon immer gewesen?
Schon immer gewesen.
Nein oder? Also als kleines Kind schon durch die Wiesen gezogen und …
Ja also dass ich Biologie studieren würde, das wusste ich glaube ich in der 1. Klasse schon.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Warum?
Also ich glaube ein Teil von dem Einfluss, also das kam durch meinen Großvater, der war Chemiker. Und mein Vater und seine drei Geschwister sind alle Geistes- und Sozialwissenschaftler geworden und mein Großvater war tief gekränkt und hat sich vorgenommen, bei seinen Enkeln das besser zu machen und hat mich von jedem Familientreffen sozusagen schnell von der Kaffeetafel wegentführt und wir haben die toten Fliegen von der Fensterbank gesammelt und unterm Mikroskop angeguckt und das fand ich schon damals richtig richtig cool.
Und was war so cool daran?
Naja, dass in diesem kleinen Fliegenflügel noch so viele komplexe Formen drin sind. Und dass das alles irgendwie so von selber gewachsen ist und dass die Fliegenkinder wieder so aussehen und das fand ich schon damals interessant.
Verstehe, also sozusagen früh auf die Bahn geschickt mit entsprechendem familienakademischen Hintergrund fällt das ja vielleicht auch etwas einfacher.
Naja aber ich musste mich dann als Naturwissenschaftler, da war ich ja dann wieder das schwarze Schaf in der Familie.
Weil die anderen alle sich mit den denkenden Wissenschaften beschäftigt haben.
Genau. Und wir mit denen, die die Fakten liefern hoffentlich.
Aber das war dann am Ende auch kein Problem?
Mit den Fakten?
Nein, da sozusagen diesen Weg weiter zu beschreiten und sich da durchzusetzen.
Nein überhaupt nicht. Nein, ich habe das auch von Anfang an echt gerne gemacht und wenn ich jetzt überlege, ob ich nochmal Biologie studieren würde, das würde ich auf jeden Fall machen und ich würde irgendwie noch mehr machen und ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe vielleicht an zu vielen Stellen nicht gut genug aufgepasst oder ich hätte mehr Kurse besuchen sollen oder so. Es gibt so viel, was da interessant dran ist.
Na gut zum Doktor hat es auf jeden Fall gereicht.
Ja.
Wo wurde das Studium denn absolviert?
In Tübingen und in Freiburg. Und danach war ich dann zwei Jahre in München und dann habe ich in München meine Doktorarbeit nach knapp zwei Jahren geschmissen und dann habe ich gesagt, so aber die Freude an der Wissenschaft, die nehmt ihr mir hier nicht. Und habe nochmal neu angefangen dann in Hamburg.
Mit demselben Thema?
Nein mit einem anderen Thema. Da war ich dann hier am Zentrum für molekulare Neurobiologie und habe mich mit spannungsabhängigen Chloridkanälen auseinandergesetzt.
Also so Nervenbahnen?
Genau.
Und das hat dann aber geklappt?
Das hat dann geklappt ja.
Super und dann bist du Biologin geworden und das war es?
Genau, ja nein das war es nicht. Ich war dann danach auch noch Postdoc, also ich war insgesamt schon sehr lange Biologin. Und habe mich da mit der molekularen Evolutionsbiologie auseinandergesetzt. Und das war auch interessant, wie man dadurch, dass man immer mehr in die molekularen Ebenen reingucken kann und die Genetik und diese ganzen Sequenzierungen immer schneller und immer günstiger werden, dass man sozusagen den Stammbaum des Lebens an einigen Stellen umsortieren muss, weil man da andere …
Über welchen Zeitraum reden wir jetzt gerade? Jahreszahl?
Jahreszahl von was? Wann ich das gemacht …
Wo diese molekulare Evolutionsbiologie auf einmal ein Thema wurde.
Das habe ich 2008-2011 gemacht.
Also da waren sozusagen so diese Gendurchbrüche auch gerade alle eingepreist?
Genau, und dieses Next Generation Sequencing und so das kam dann gerade. Dass man halt so richtig größere Datenmengen auch generieren konnte. Und das fand ich interessant. Weil sonst hat man bisher, also seit Charles Darwin haben wir ja immer nur nach äußeren Merkmalen den Stammbaum des Lebens sortiert oder auch mal natürlich in Pflanzen und Tiere reingeguckt und geguckt, wie es da drin aussieht. Aber nicht halt auf genetischer Ebene.
Hat sich da viel durch geändert?
Einiges hat sich dadurch geändert ja.
Zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel irgendwie innerhalb der Reptilien wurden die Krokodile wieder näher zu den Vögeln gerückt und weiter von den andren Reptilien weg.
Oh die Vögel und die Krokodile stecken sozusagen unter einer Decke?
Die stecken unter einer Decke ja.
Den Verdacht hatte ich schon länger. Sind ja ohnehin sozusagen die Weltmeister des Überlebens oder?
Vögel und Krokodile?
Ja vor allem die Krokodile und die Schildkröten glaube ich auch noch. Sind die nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen die ältesten, die so noch rumfleuchen und eigentlich auch schon damals nicht sehr viel anders waren als heute?
Das weiß ich gar nicht. Nein also sozusagen diese lebenden Fossilien sind dann eher noch andere. Das sind so Quastenflosser und solche Dinge. Solche Viecher ja. Aber die Schildkröten werden natürlich selbst als Individuum sehr sehr alt.
Ja das stimmt auch noch. Na gut wir wollen nicht über Krokodile und Schildkröten reden, sondern doch noch ein bisschen über die Wissenschaft sprechen. Jetzt hast du ja noch so ein – darf ich Hobby sagen? – Oder so eine private Passion, sagen wir es vielleicht mal so.
Private Passion ist deutlich besser als Hobby.
Ja ich weiß. Und das firmiert unter dem Titel Science Slam.
Das ist ja mein Beruf der Science Slam, ich mache ja nichts anderes. Ich habe zwei Angestellte, die dauernd da sitzen und wir machen den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als Veranstaltungen organisieren.
Aha, na gut das ist ja dann sozusagen eine geschäftsmäßige Passion.
Genau, die es dann geworden ist ja.
Also wie kam es denn dazu?
Wie kam es dazu. Es kam dazu, dass ich vom Science Slam gehört habe das erste Mal 2008. Da hatte mir auf einer Konferenz hatte mir der Markus Weißkopf, der damals am Haus der Wissenschaft in Braunschweig war, hat mir erzählt, dass er die Idee hatte, einen Science Slam zu machen und die das da gemacht haben in Braunschweig. Und die Idee wäre so und so, wie beim Poetry Slam, nur halt Wissenschaftler stellen ihre eigenen Themen vor, statt ihrer eigenen Texte. Und ich habe gedacht, oh wie geil ist das denn, das muss ich auch machen. Das ist ja wirklich die allerbeste Idee, die es jemals auf der Welt gab. Und dann hat er mich auch ermutigt und hat gesagt, ja komm mal her und guck es dir an. Da habe ich gesagt, das brauche ich gar nicht anzugucken. Also bevor ich meinen ersten Science Slam gesehen habe, den es halt bis dahin nur in Braunschweig gab, hatte ich schon eine Location gemietet und eine Moderatorin klar gemacht und die ersten Slamer gesucht und allen meinen Leuten, Freunden und Bekannten und so weiter in den Ohren gelegen, dass sie da auftreten müssen.
Also der Slam kommt, also wurde ja schon gerade erwähnt, Poetry Slam ich glaube die waren die ersten oder?
Poetry Slam ist eine amerikanische Erfindung und die ist dann so in den 80er Jahren auch schon nach Deutschland geschwappt. Ende der 80er Jahre. Science Slam hingegen ist eine deutsche Erfindung. Also den ersten Science Slam hat es gegeben 2006 in Darmstadt und in Braunschweig ist er dann zwei Jahre später unabhängig davon auch erfunden worden. 2009 habe ich dann meinen ersten hier in der Ponybar gemacht. Die war zum bersten voll wirklich, das tropfte quasi von der Decke und es waren irgendwie 120 Leute in einem Raum, wo nur 60 rein gehen. Und es waren draußen wahnsinnig viele Leute, die wir nicht mehr reinlassen konnten. Und dann war Spiegel Online da und Zeit Online und am nächsten Tag hatte ich 20 E-Mails von Leuten, die gesagt haben, ich habe das gelesen, das ist ja toll, das will ich auch machen, was braucht man dazu?
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal kurz erklären, was das ist. Also ein Poetry Slam ist, Leute, die Gedichte schreiben, stellen sich auf die Bühne, tragen jene vor. Im Idealfall in humoristischer Absicht oder zumindest machen sie es so gut, so unterhaltsam oder so ansprechend, dass das Publikum, was dann dazu eingeladen ist, in Begeisterungsstürme ausbricht und ich glaube, am Ende wird auch immer noch der Beste gewählt. Also dieser Wettbewerbsaspekt war schon immer auch ein Teil davon, also zumindest von der Poetry Slam Szene. Science Slam übernimmt diese Idee, tauscht aber quasi die Gedichte gegen das Erläutern von wissenschaftlichen Zusammenhängen und wissenschaftlicher Arbeit aus. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja. Ich sage es halt immer so, beim Poetry Slam kommen halt junge Schreiberlinge auf die Bühne, haben eine begrenzte Zeit, meistens fünf Minuten und dürfen da ihre eigenen Texte vortragen. Und beim Science Slam ist es so, dass halt junge Wissenschaftler auf die Bühne kommen, das sind ja auch Nachwuchswissenschaftler, wir haben da jetzt keine Leute, die eh schon super bekannt sind, weil sie schon seit 40 Jahren am gleichen Protein forschen, sondern es sind wirklich relativ junge Leute, Doktoranden, ein paar Postdocs, aber wir hatten auch schon Leute, die ihre Bachelorarbeit vorgestellt haben. Und die tragen halt ihre eigenen Forschungsprojekte vor oder erzählen davon oder erzählen Grundlagen davon. Vielleicht Methoden, die sie verwenden. Und die haben dafür 10 Minuten Zeit und werden auch hinterher vom Publikum dafür bewertet.
Aber es muss auch die eigene Arbeit sein?
Es muss die eigene Arbeit sein, genau wie es beim Poetry Slam die eigenen Texte sein müssen. Also man darf jetzt nicht, ich dürfte mich jetzt nicht hinstellen und über schwarze Löcher reden, nur weil ich die so cool finde, sondern es muss halt was sein, wo ich im Zweifel derjenige bin oder diejenige bin, die auf der Welt am meisten Ahnung davon hat. Also es muss richtig das eigene sein und ich glaube, es funktioniert auch nur so. Das passt halt sehr gut zu diesem Slam-Format. Es gibt ja auch so Singer-Songwriter-Slam, wo die Leute ihre eigenen Lieder singen. Naja beim Poetry Slam halt das mit den Texten. Es gibt ja auch einen Diary Slam, wo Leute aus ihren alten Tagebüchern vorlesen und so. Und das jemand wirklich sehr stark als Person auf der Bühne für das steht, was er oder sie da gerade vorträgt.
Wo bei diesen Castingshows da darf ja auch mal gepowert werden, das ist hier sozusagen jetzt nicht teil.
Es ist auch keine Castingshow. Großes Missverständnis.
Ja so Singer-Songwriter-Kontext kann man natürlich schnell so missverstehen, dass man jetzt hier Deutschland sucht den Superstar -mäßig versucht hier aufzutreten. Also es ist einfach fokussiert auf die eigene Arbeit und man versucht, die Leute dazu zu ermuntern, ihre eigene Forschung, ihren eigenen Erkenntnisse und ihre eigenen Arbeitsmethoden quasi auf eine Art und Weise darzustellen, dass es dann auch nicht langweilig ist?
Dass es nicht langweilig ist, dass es die Leute inhaltlich verstehen, dass die Leute vielleicht auch verstehen, warum es wichtig ist, dass man das erforscht. Ich finde immer, das ist auch die Gelegenheit, eine Lanze für die Grundlagenforschung zu brechen und zu sagen, nein das hat jetzt keine Anwendung, wir wollen wissen, wie die Welt funktioniert und wir geben da auch irre viel Geld für aus. Zum Teil, wenn es halt um so Teilchenbeschleuniger und so was geht und der praktische Nutzung ist einfach null. Und trotzdem ist es toll, das zu machen. Und es ist wahnsinnig befriedigend Wissenschaftler zu sein. Das möchte ich halt auch gerne so transportiert haben auf der Bühne. Und es funktioniert auch häufig, und das sind auch die Themen, die beim Publikum gut ankommen. So diese richtigen Grundlagen, was ist eigentlich um uns rum.
Womit fing es denn an? Was waren denn so die ersten?
Die ersten Themen beim Science Slam?
Passte das gleich alles von Anfang an? Also war das sozusagen …
Also bei meinem allerersten Science Slam hat einer gesprochen über nachhaltige Fischerei vor Island, das war ein VWLer. Dann hat ein Philosoph gesprochen über Ethik bei Pharma-Tests.
Also es dürfen auch Geisteswissenschaftler mitmachen?
Es dürfen auch Geisteswissenschaftler mitmachen.
Ah da kommt es ja dann wieder zusammen sozusagen.
Es dürfen alle Wissenschaftler mitmachen.
Die Versöhnung mit der Familie dann auch.
Es dürfen alle Wissenschaftler mitmachen. Es muss hochschulangebunden sein. Also wir haben manchmal Leute, die sagen, ich bin seit 20 Jahren in der Personalabteilung, ich weiß jetzt, wie man den perfekten Bewerber findet und ich möchte gern beim Science Slam auftreten, so jemand darf nicht mitmachen. Das ist nämlich keine Wissenschaft.
Aber es gibt ja vielleicht auch Wissenschaftler, die eher so ohne eine Hochschulkarriere daherkommen?
Ja das ist halt so für uns auch so ein bisschen, so stellen wir halt die Qualität einigermaßen sicher. Es gibt halt auch Spinner. Also es gibt auf der einen Seite Spinner, die sagen, ich habe ein Buch geschrieben zu dem und dem Thema und das will ich eigentlich promoten, und ich tue aber so, als wäre es ein Science Slam. Und dann gibt es auch Leute, die Firmen gründen und bei uns auf die Bühne wollen und halt sagen, ich habe meine Masterarbeit darüber gemacht, oh und jetzt habe ich mich mit dieser Idee selbstständig gemacht. Guck mal hier, das ist die Homepage und das sind unsere Dienstleistungen. Genau das wollen wir halt nicht haben. Und dann gibt es ja auch echte Spinner. Ich weiß, ich musste mal jemanden wirklich … jemandem der angereist war aus dem westfälischen, eine Frau, der musste ich fünf Minuten vorher klar machen, nein du kommst nicht auf diese Bühne, weil Anthroposophie ist keine Wissenschaft, auch wenn du sagst, du möchtest beim Science Slam mitmachen.
Und du hast dich sehr viel mit Anthroposophie beschäftigt. Nein, Science ist Science. Und da achte ich halt drauf, dass es sehr stark geschützt ist.
Das heißt ein Science Slam ist im Prinzip, also was ist jetzt hier die Organisationsform, wie ihr das hier betreibt?
Also ich bin sozusagen selbstständig und mache Veranstaltungen und diese vor allen Dingen, aber auch noch andere Veranstaltungen, die irgendwas mit Wissenschaftskommunikation zu tun haben oder auch nur mit, Leute erzählen lassen, was sie interessantes machen. also zum Beispiel die Nerdnight mache ich hier in Hamburg auch. Insgesamt sind wir ja ziemlich viele Science Slam Organisatoren inzwischen. Ich würde sagen so 25 Leute in Deutschland, die in 1-5 Städten jeweils irgendwie ihre Science Slams organisieren und wir treffen uns immer einmal im Jahr zu einer Slam Master Konferenz und legen Regeln fest und …
Aber sind unabhängig voneinander arbeitende?
Genau, wir sind auch kein Verein oder so. Also wir haben keinen offiziellen Dachverband, sind kein offizielles Gremium. Und es klappt sehr gut muss ich sagen, auch diese jährlichen Treffen und dann legen wir fest, wo die deutschen Meisterschaften dann stattfinden und wo diese Regionalentscheide vorher stattfinden und welche Städte dazu gehören und nach welchen Kriterien die Leute mitmachen dürfen und welche Slams Leute dahin entsenden dürfen und solche Fragen beantworten wir da und legen wir fest.
Genau, da können wir vielleicht mal diesen Ablauf auch nochmal erläutern. Also es gibt diese Veranstaltung mittlerweile in wie vielen Städten gefühlt?
Gefühlt irgendwie 30-40 würde ich sagen. Also ich würde sagen, in praktisch jeder deutschen Universitätsstadt, aber manchmal ist es so, dass irgendein Doktorand sagt, super machen wir das und der ruft das ins Leben und dann ist er mit seiner Doktorarbeit fertig und hat einen Job und dann schläft der ganze Science Slam ein, weil das jetzt niemand direkt dann übernimmt. Und dann zwei Jahre später kommt wieder jemand auf die Idee und sagt, das sollten wir mal wieder beleben.
Schweiz, Österreich?
Ja.
Schweiz, Österreich auch schon lange dabei und auch im regen Austausch mit uns. Andere Länder auch wirklich, Finnland, Schweden, auch schon mehrere Jahre dabei.
Auch dabei?
Aber die machen das auf Finnisch und Schwedisch?
Die machen das auf Finnisch und Schwedisch. Wir haben allerdings auch seit 2014 europäische Science Slam Meisterschaften.
Die dann wahrscheinlich auf englisch stattfinden?
Die dann auf englisch stattfinden und die waren 2014 in Kopenhagen und 2015 in Wien. Wir machen das wie beim Eurovision Songcontest, dass der Sieger immer das nächste austragende Land wird, und dieses Jahr sind sie dann nämlich in Deutschland, und zwar in Hamburg am 14. Oktober.
Okay und das ist genauso organisiert, bloß halt international?
Bloß halt international. Also aus europäischen Ländern kommen die Leute nur bisher. Also mit den anderen würde man auch noch nicht so groß was zusammenkriegen. Aber es ist halt sozusagen ein europäisches Finale, und kein Weltfinale.
Wie läuft das jetzt ab? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also so ein Science Slam ist .. ich war mal bei einem, muss ich dazu sagen, das war glaube ich die Endausscheidung in Berlin?
Ja 2014.
Ja vor zwei Jahren und ich fand das sehr unterhaltsam. Also ich fand die Atmosphäre war kolossal, das Publikum fand ich interessant, also man merkte einfach, das sind einfach interessierte Leute, die auch so Spaß an Wissen haben. Da sehe ich jetzt auch nicht wenig Überschneidungen mit Podcasthörer-Publikum im übrigen. Ja und da lag einfach schon mal was in der Luft so und dann ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Leute da an dem Abend präsentiert haben, 8 oder so in der Größenordnung. Das war alles sehr unterhaltsam, man merkte, da brennt so ein bisschen die Luft, also es war wirklich, jeder hat eigentlich alles reingeworfen, was so ging. Also an Humor, an Inhalt natürlich auch. Sehr spaßige Präsentationen noch mit dabei. Es gibt einen Zeitrahmen, wie ist der so?
10 Minuten.
Und man darf alles verwenden, was man an Hilfsmitteln verbraucht. Also Requisiten, PowerPoint, was auch immer. Im Gegensatz zum Poetry Slam, wo man glaube ich noch nicht mal singen darf, da darf man wirklich nur sprechen.
10 Minuten Zeit hat man.
Aber bei Wissenschaftlern darf alles explodieren, und Laser.
Ja genau. Feuer, bitte vorher anmelden. Genau und dann haben wir normalerweise bei unseren Science Slams 5-7 Leute, die auftreten, jeder hat 10 Minuten Zeit. Die kommen da alle hin von ganz verschiedenen Fächern, mit ganz verschiedenen Themen. Je unterschiedlicher, desto besser wird eigentlich der Abend. Dann losen wir am Anfang die Reihenfolge aus, weil derjenige der anfängt hat es halt irgendwie immer am schwersten. Wir machen die Bewertung nach jedem einzelnen Vortrag, und zwar in der Form, dass wir vorher so Wertungstafelsets mit Zahlen von 1-10 drauf lose im Publikum verteilen. Und nach jedem einzelnen Vortag sagen wir, so ihr habt jetzt zwei Minuten Zeit oder eine Minute Zeit, unterhaltet euch mit euern Umsitzenden darüber, wie viele Punkte ihr demjenigen geben wollt. Und dann unterhalten die sich 1-2 Minuten und das funktioniert halt sehr gut.
Dass die Leute über Themen ins Gespräch kommen, wo sie vorher gedacht haben, verstehe ich nichts von, kann ich nichts zu sagen. Dass sozusagen diese Hemmschwelle, was über Wissenschaft zu sagen oder sich eine Meinung zu bilden, durch diesen Zeitdruck da überwunden wird. Und einige Leute sagen, der hat aber noch einen Notizzettel in der Hand gehabt, dann finden die sozusagen das eher schlecht, wenn jemand seinen Vortrag nicht völlig frei gehalten hat. Und die anderen sagen, ja aber dafür ist es ein Thema, wovon wir alle profitieren, gerade so erneuerbare Energie ist so ein Thema.
Worum es ja eigentlich jetzt nicht geht, bestimmte Disziplinen jetzt per sé zu bevorteilen, nur weil es um diese Themen geht.
Nein geht es nicht, aber ich wollte jetzt nur darstellen, wie verschieden auch die Ansatzpunkte sind von diesen Gruppen, über was sie diskutieren. Ja und insofern hat es auch so etwas sehr sozialisierendes unter den Zuschauern, die sich da so ein bisschen kennenlernen. Also meine Schwester ist bis heute mit Leuten befreundet, die sie in einer Science Slam Wertungsgruppe kennengelernt hat.
Okay, schon eine ganze Familie gegründet.
Ja ich kenne einen Fall, es gibt ein Science Slam Baby, so was kann schon laufen.
Ist das denn schon mal wissenschaftlich bearbeitet worden, wie das Abstimmungsverhalten sich bei den ersten gegenüber den letzten verhält. Also wenn man sozusagen alle Science Slam Ergebnisse macht, sind die Gewinner gleichmäßig verteilt von Anfang bis zum Ende oder?
Nein die am Ende haben es halt leichter. Also ich glaube, das liegt daran …
Man hat halt schon alles gesehen und dann werden die hohen Noten rausgezogen.
Genau, am Anfang hält man sich noch Luft nach oben frei und am Ende haben die Leute auch jeder drei Bier getrunken und finden einfach Sachen lustiger, die sie am Anfang noch nicht so lustig gefunden hätten.
Ja aber ist das dann nicht ein bisschen fies?
Ja genau. Wir machen es ja auch nicht, damit jemand gewinnt. Und das wissen auch die Leute, die bei uns auf der Bühne sind, dass sie es deswegen machen, weil dann 500 Leute mitbekommen, an was man gerade forscht und nicht wie bei meiner Doktorarbeit 30. Und dass man zusammen auf der Bühne steht und deswegen gibt es bei uns auch keine großen Preise. Wir versuchen halt diese Konkurrenz auf der Bühne möglichst niedrig zu halten und gering zu halten. Die kennen sich aj auch oft untereinander, die sollen halt einfach alle einen netten Abend haben. Und dieses Abstimmungsverhalten ist dazu da, dass das Publikum über Wissenschaft ins Gespräch kommt.
Also auch wenn man sich am Eurovision Songcontest ein wenig organisatorisch organisiert hat, geht es hier nicht primär um den Contest, sondern es geht halt um den Slam. Es geht sozusagen um die Darbietung und die Unterhaltung?
Genau.
Gab es denn eigentlich irgendwas, also ich meine, worüber wir jetzt ja eigentlich reden ist im Prinzip eine moderne Form der Wissenschaftskommunikation, die ja ungewöhnlich ist, weil Wissenschaftskommunikation nimmt man halt gemeinhin als eine trockene Sache wahr. Da werden irgendwie Zeitungen gedruckt und Papers veröffentlicht und ab und zu läuft mal was im Radio. Pressemitteilungen werden vielleicht noch geschrieben, aber darüber hinaus gibt es nur so einige Highlights, so was man so aus dem Fernsehen kennt, wenn dann halt dieser – wie hieß er noch gleich, der Tierbiologe aus dem …
Heinz Sielmann.
Und sein Vorgänger noch.
Grzimek.
Der mit seinem Affen und so weiter, der auch auf seine Art und Weise Wissenschaft in dem Moment vielleicht mehr Naturleben – wie auch immer man das jetzt definieren will – aber wissenschaftlich geprägt solche Themen halt in die Öffentlichkeit gebracht haben, auf eine vergleichsweise unterhaltsame Art und Weise. Slams sind da was ganz anderes.
Sind etwas ganz andres, bei Hans Jemand fällt mir ein, was vielleicht noch dazu beigetragen haben mag, dass ich Biologin geworden bin, weil Tagesschau und Expeditionen ins Tierreich waren das einzige was ich bis ich 18 war gucken durfte im Fernsehen. ich hatte da sehr strikte Eltern. Ich wusste halt glaube ich gar nicht, dass es noch was andres gibt als Biologie.
Ja das geht heute nicht mehr.
Nein das geht heute so was von nicht mehr. Ist das was ganz anderes?
Also drehen wir es doch mal um. Wie ist es denn angenommen worden? Wie war denn jetzt die Reaktion in der Community? Gibt es da nur so einige, die sagen, ja toll und der Rest so, ja nein für mich ist das jetzt nichts. Oder hat sich daraus schon irgendwas entwickelt?
Die Community, die wissenschaftliche Community, was die da sagen?
Ja.
Viele Leute finden es toll. Also viele auch von den Zuschauern, Leute, die da selbst studieren oder irgendwie an der Uni sind, finden es toll. Ich hatte allerdings auch immer wieder mal, auch bis heute, wo sich das Format ja wirklich bewährt hat und wirklich viele Leute immer anzieht Jahr für Jahr, habe ich immer wieder Leute, die sagen, ja ich will aber nicht gefilmt werden, weil mein Chef darf nicht wissen, dass ich hier mitgemacht habe. Oder Leute, die sagen, ja ich wollte mir so ein Modell leihen. Neulich wollte sich eine Science Slamerin das Modell einer Kaulquappe ausleihen, was seit 30 Jahren im Schrank vor sich einstaubte, um das auf der Bühne zu zeigen, weil sie an der Froschentwicklung irgendwie arbeitet. Da hat auch ihr Chef gesagt, nein darfst ud nicht mitnehmen, so was unterstütze ich nicht. So was gibt es hin und wieder.
Ist das ein Generationenproblem?
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Generationsproblem. Die Leute sagen, oh Trivialisierung der Wissenschaft, davor haben wir Angst. Ich finde das total albern. Weil wir … also ich meine aus dem Life Science Bereich, da ist die Forschung schon relativ teuer. Es gibt noch teurere, aber die ist schon ordentlich teuer und es sind Steuergelder, die wir da verbraten und das muss man den Leuten erklären, was man macht, den ganzen Tag. Das ist echt auch eine Verpflichtung. Und deshalb finde ich das arrogant und engstirnig, wenn jemand sagt, das wollen wir nciht.
Was ist denn das für eine Zielgruppe, wer kommt denn da hin? Wisst ihr das?
Also das einzige, was ich relativ sicher weiß, weil wir einfach ermäßigte Tickets verkaufen, ist, dass wir so ungefähr ein Drittel Schüler und Studenten haben. Die anderen zwei Drittel sind wirklich sehr gemischt. Also meine Lieblings-Science-Slam-Zuschauerin, die keinen einzigen Science-Slam in Hamburg verpasst ist inzwischen 82 Jahre. Erzählt immer, dass sie kein Abitur hat, sich aber schon ihr Leben lang für Wissenschaft interessiert, die ist Künstlerin. Und sagt, so gut wie beim Science-Slam bekomme ich es sonst nirgends. Nicht im Fernsehen, nicht in der Zeitung, beim Science-Slam ist es einfach perfekt aufbereitet und erklärt. Also Leute, ich glaube wir haben auch viel, wir sind halt hier in Hamburg zum Beispiel in dem Bunker an der Feldstraße, in dem Übel und Gefährlich. Das ist halt so mitten in der Schanze, Reeperbahn die Ecke und ich glaube, da kriegen wir halt auch viel so Schanzenpublikum.
Das sind Leute, die haben vielleicht studiert oder vielleicht auch nicht studiert, aber sind halt selbst keine Wissenschaftler, die sind Grafiker, Programmierer, solche Leute.
Aber wissensorientierte Menschen?
Ja, wissensorientiert.
Oder erkenntnisbejahende.
Wissenschaftlich interessiert und die vielleicht auch mehr Lust haben auf Science-Slam als auf Poetry-Slam. Leute, die abends weggehen, die halt irgendwie sich gerne verabreden und die es halt mögen, mit 500 Leuten in einem Raum zu sein und jemandem zuzuhören. Und meine Moderatorin, die auch ganz viele Poetry-Slams moderiert, die hat mal gesagt auf die Frage, warum die Leute zum Science-Slam wirklich in Massen kommen und beim Poetry-Slam ja kommen auch wahnsinnig viele Leute, aber was beim Science-Slam so besonders wäre, da meinte sie, naja beim Poetry-Slam geht es halt immer nur um Liebe und Tod. Und beim Science-Slam geht es halt um echte Themen. Halt das was die Leute mögen.
Wobei es ja dann auch um Liebe und Tod gehen kann, in dem Moment, wo man sich da wissenschaftlich auseinandersetzt. Also das schließt das ja noch nicht mal aus.
Nein selbstverständlich ja.
Ich frage mich jetzt, also als Event fand ich das super unterhaltsam. Ich sehe auch diesen positiven Effekt. Man merkte das ganz stark, dass die Wissenschaftlerinnen waren gefordert, einerseits schnell, andererseits halt auch zwangsläufig präzise das eigene Schaffen zusammenzufassen, aber dann auch die Erkenntnisse so darzulegen und gleichzeitig eben auch noch das notwendige Basiswissen mit zu vermitteln, um überhaupt zu verstehen, worüber geredet wird. Mit anderen Worten, man wird zu so einer extremen Abstraktion gezwungen, was ja nicht einfach ist. Und oft, und das empfinde ich auch, insofern bin ich auch so ein bisschen überrascht, dass das jetzt sozusagen in Deutschland gestartet ist, ganz ehrlich gesagt. Ich stelle immer fest, dass die Präsentationskultur generell, also unabhängig jetzt von der Wissenschaft in Deutschland verbesserungswürdig ist.
Man kann hier doch sehr schnell eingeschlafene Füße bekommen, während man so in dem Angloraum auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise unterhalten wird. Hier zeigt sich, dass das eben nicht unbedingt so sein muss auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite, dass man dadurch ja auch einen ganz neuen Still eigentlich auch trainiert, der vielleicht sonst einem ein bisschen zu kurz kommt. Weil man eben immer nur unter seines gleichen präsentiert. Man hat da so seine Stelen, die man dann so auf Konferenzen hinhält und dann kann man davor sich mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten oder man hält halt mal einen Vortrag. Hohes Basiswissen kann man voraussetzen. Das heißt man diskutiert im Prinzip nur noch so im Ergebnisbereich, aber man macht nicht immer nur diesen vollen Schwung, weil das hat man halt wahrscheinlich nur bei so einem Science-Slam oder halt auf einer Party in der Küche, wenn irgendwie da alle wieder dicht gedrängt um so einen kleinen Tisch zusammensitzen. Und eben auch genauso aus anderen Disziplinen kommen.
Was kann denn sozusagen der wissenschaftliche Körper selber, das wissenschaftliche System aus solchen Veranstaltungen für sich gewinnen und sollte es vielleicht auch sogar noch mehr Slams direkt an Hochschulen geben? Oder eine ähnliche Präsentationskultur vielleicht.
Ich glaube Präsentationskultur auf jeden Fall, da ist extrem viel Luft nach oben auch noch. Also ich kenne Leute, die unterrichten Didaktik der Biologie oder Didaktik der Chemie und die halten Vorträge, die einfach assistierten Lesen sind. Also die lesen ja auch Folien praktisch vor. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie so was passieren kann und warum. Also warum jemand dann Didaktiker geworden ist, wenn er das selbst nicht beherrscht. Naja. Es ist wirklich zum Teil grauenvoll. ich glaube wofür es zum Beispiel innerhalb der Uni gut wäre, ist, auch zu sagen, man hat ja manchmal so Institute, da arbeiten halt 300 Leute und keiner weiß so richtig was der andere macht und dann gibt es ja oft so, also ich kenne das auch von Instituten, wo ich Diplomarbeit gemacht habe beispielsweise. Da ist halt einmal in der Woche, da ist dann freitags jeweils ein Doktorand erzählt was er macht, und zwar irgendwie 1,5 Stunden lang.
Und das macht jeder einmal während seiner Doktorarbeit oder zweimal. Weil so viele Doktoranden sind halt an diesem Institut, dass man da nicht öfter drankommt. Und dann geht man da hin und hört sich das ein bisschen halbwach an und denkt dann so, ja so ungefähr so ein bisschen habe ich was. Ich habe so eine Ahnung was die machen in dem Labor direkt unter mir. Aber wenn man da so einen Science-Slam machen würde und sagen würde, okay wir haben jetzt 10 Arbeitsgruppen, aus jeder Arbeitsgruppe einer stellt mal vor was er macht und wir haben das in zwei Stunden durch. Ich glaube, da würde man viel viel mehr voneinander lernen können in solchen Settings. Und auch Wissen, gerade innerhalb von Instituten, wenn da die Konkurrenz idealerweise nicht so hoch ist unter den Arbeitsgruppen, dann profitieren ja auch alle davon, wenn die wissen, ah der beherrscht die Methode und ich brauche die eigentlich jetzt, also soll der mir das mal beibringen.
Auch sozusagen um die eigenen Fähigkeiten auch besser erst mal sich rumsprechen zu lassen, sonst wurschteln immer alle immer so in ihrem Büro vor sich hin und keiner weiß eigentlich was geschieht.
Genau, wenn man sagt, wir haben das, wir machen das, wir kennen das, wir kennen uns damit aus und dann weiß man, wen man fragen kann und so. Ich glaube dafür, für so interne Kommunikation ist es echt sehr gut geeignet. Und was sie sich schon …
Macht das schon jemand?
Von Unis weiß ich es jetzt nicht. Nein. Ich weiß, dass Unternehmen so was machen, die auch forschen, die sich so gegenseitig ihre Sachen vorstellen.
Die jetzt so ein bisschen ähnlich sind oder die sich auch konkret an dem Science-Slam orientieren?
Die durch den Science-Slam auf die Idee gekommen sind. So wir machen das jetzt mal, aber nicht mit einer Postersession. Ja, also das gibt es auch innerhalb von so Communities. Ich weiß nicht, bei der deutschen physikalischen Gesellschaft zum Beispiel, der DPG, die machen auch schon ganz lange Science-Slams und da ist es dann so, entweder man hält einen Vortrag oder man hat so ein Poster und stellt sich davor und erklärt es den Leuten oder man macht beim Science-Slam mit. Das ist sozusagen von Anfang an drei verschiedene Sachen, wie man da seine Arbeit vorstellen kann, unter denen man wählen kann. Das ist das was mir einfällt und ansonsten können die Leute natürlich auf jeden Fall von der Art zu präsentieren lernen. Und da sind sie ja bei uns auch total zurückhaltend, wenn es darum geht, mal das Publikum direkt anzusprechen und irgendwas zu fragen und so. Das merke ich halt auch, wenn wir irgendwelche amerikanischen Wissenschaftler oder auch britische Wissenschaftler im Labor hatten, die da ja sehr sehr weit sind. Viel machen, was Outreach angeht. Das war halt sehr erfrischend.
Dass die einfach auch mal erzählen. Weiß ich nicht. Ein Mikrobiologe, der anfängt und sagt, ihr denkt alle, wenn ihr morgens in der Dusche steht, das glibschige Zeugs unten bei euch am Duschvorhang wäre Seife, aber es ist keine Seife, es sind Bakterien und zwar die und die und die. Und das ist schon so ein Einstieg, den halt Deutsche sonst nicht haben.
Ja Realitätsbezug.
Ja genau.
Wie könnte denn eine Uni das umsetzen? Einfach indem man einfach auch nur einen Science-Slam macht, oder sollte man das sozusagen schon so richtig denken als Teil des normalen Lehrbetriebs?
Ich glaube es sollte mehr darauf geachtet werden, wie die Leute vortragen und nicht nur Inhalte. Also ich gebe ja auch viele Workshops, wie halte ich einen guten Vortrag oder wie halte ich einen guten Science-Slam-Vortrag. Und was den meisten Leuten nicht bewusst ist, ist glaube ich, dass keiner wegen der Fakten zu dem Vortrag geht, sondern man geht zu einem Vortrag, um den Menschen hinter dem Thema zu sehen und kennenzulernen. Und wenn man sagt, ach ich halte keinen Vortag, ich kann genauso gut ein PDF rumschicken, dann muss man auch keinen Vortag dazu halten, dann kann man genauso gut ein PDF rumschicken und spart ziemlich vielen Leuten Zeit. Und insofern ist es gut, wenn man einfach einen persönlichen Bezug zu seinem Thema herstellt. Und wenn man das den Leuten schon beibringen würde, wenn sie ihre ersten Vorträge halten. Halt keine reinen Referate, aber wo sie wirklich nur das Lehrbuchwissen wiedergeben.
Aber sobald sie über ihre eigene Arbeit sprechen, also diese Work in Progress Treffen, die es da immer gibt, da wäre es glaube ich gut zu zeigen, irgendwas persönliches reinzubringen.
Ich weiß nicht, bisher mag es vielleicht noch kein Problem gewesen sein, Leute zu gewinnen, solche Vorträge zu halten in ausreichendem Maße. Aber es gibt doch sicherlich auch mal versuche gegeben habe, wo man dachte, so hier das was du machst ist doch total cool, hast du nicht mal Lust da bei dem Slam beizutragen, wo dann so mit Zurückhaltung reagiert wurde, ach nein nichts für mich, Bühne, so viele Leute, ach oh Gott da kriege ich ja kein Wort. Also so was kenne ich sozusagen aus dem deutschen Kulturraum immer wieder auch an anderen Stellen. Das ist ja sicherlich hier auch verbreitet?
Also am Anfang war es unmöglich Leute zu finden. Also es war jetzt nicht übertrieben. Ich habe für meinen ersten Science-Slam ein halbes Jahr lang über nichts anderes geredet.
Um Leute zu überzeugen?
Um Leute zu finden, die mitmachen ja. Und dann habe ich halt vier Leute für meinen ersten Science-Slam gefunden. Und ich habe wirklich alles getan. Ich habe Wissenschaftler, die ich kannte, irgendwie bekniet und denen davon vorgeschwärmt von einer Veranstaltung, die ich selbst noch nie erlebt hatte.
Das wird total toll.
Ja es war dann glücklicherweise auch total toll. Einer hat sogar aus Berlin gesagt, ey die Idee finde ich einfach nur gut, ich mache mit.
Und dann wurde es einfacher?
Also es war am Anfang wahnsinnig schwer.
Aber was sagt man den Leuten, die sich so zieren?
Die sich so zieren, also wer nicht will, der muss nicht. Und ich biete halt auch den Leuten vorher an, dass sie mir ihre Präsentation schicken können, dass wir die zusammen durchgehen, dass wir uns mal unterhalten über deren Forschungsthema und ich mal sozusagen von der Laienseite, weil bei den meisten Themen bin ich ja Laie, dann einfach so dumme Fragen stelle und gucke, was mich als Laie vielleicht daran interessieren würde oder wie weit ich da schon Kenntnisse mitbringe. Das biete ich den Leuten an. Viele Leute nehmen das nicht in Anspruch, was auch gut ist, weil die Leute sagen, die wollen irgendwie ihr eigenes Ding und ihren eigenen Stil da finden und sich irgendwie nicht reinreden lassen. Und ansonsten hat ja auch jeder das recht, sich zu blamieren. Ich meine das passiert halt auch hin und wieder, dass Leute richtig schlecht sind. Also ich überrede niemanden. Es gibt inzwischen auch genug Leute. Aber so 2009/10/11 war es schon … musste man schon viele Leute irgendwie überzeugen.
Wenn man sie jetzt nicht mehr überreden muss oder zumindest das nicht unbedingt will, was sind denn so die Tipps, die man sozusagen mitgibt. Da wird es ja sicherlich Fragen geben, so ach ja ich würde das gerne machen, aber ich weiß nicht so recht?
Ein Tipp ist schonmal, mit anderen Laien reden. Mit Freunden, Familie und gucken, was hat man vielleicht für Analogien, die man verwenden kann, um Sachen zu erklären, um Sachen einfacher zu machen. Dann was viele Leute unterschätzen, wenn man zu den Leuten gehört, die sich leicht verzetteln, in dem was sie erzählen, dann wirklich ausformulieren und auf 10 Minuten bringen und das dann quasi auswendig lernen und wenn es einem komisch vorkommt, wie man das auswendig lernt, dann halt den Text anpassen. Das ist ganz schwer, so zu schreiben wir man spricht, aber das kann man dann anpassen. Und dann wirklich sich also den Vortrag so oft zu üben, dass man sich da komplett sicher fühlt und dass man dann auch … das einem wieder die Freiheit gibt, spontan aus der Situation heraus, sich nochmal auf seinen Vorredner zu beziehen oder auf irgendeine Besonderheit vor Ort oder auf das Publikum oder so. Das ist glaube ich wichtig. Sich dann …
Ja also wenn jemand so eine Analogie hat nicht für jede Einzelheit eine neue Analogie aufmachen, sondern sich sozusagen in einem Bild bleiben für das was man erklären muss. Und wenn es nicht passt, dann nicht erst hindengeln, sondern irgendwie was anderes nehmen und was besseres suchen. Ja dann ich denk auch immer, es ist gut beim Publikum eher zu wenig als zu viel vorauszusetzen. weil das einfach für eine besser Stimmung sorgt, wenn man was erklärt, was einige oder die meisten Leute im Publikum schon wissen denken die so, ach das habe ich schon mal gehört, ist so, fühlen sich tendenziell schlauer dabei.
Ich bin hier am richtigen Ort so, das ist mein Blues ja.
Ja genau. Genau und wenn man mit so was anfängt und keiner versteht das, dann denken die, oh pf ich habe keine Ahnung, ich bin dumm oder so. Es macht einfach nicht so eine gute Stimmung im Publikum.
Ja man kann ja auch nicht jeden Begriff wirklich voraussetzen.
Ja eben.
Ich finde es auch gerade manchmal sehr interessiert, Begriffe auch nochmal komplett neu definiert zu bekommen, von denen ich eigentlich meine, sie schon richtig verstanden zu haben und dann wird entweder nochmal eine komplett neue Facette aufgemacht, wo ich mir dachte, ah ja so rum kann man das ja auch betrachten oder die mir überhaupt erst den letzten Drive gibt, so etwas was ich immer so meine. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, wie war das jetzt nochmal mit dem Strom und dem Widerstand und so. Und wenn man dann einfach ein schönes Bildnis geliefert bekommt, dann hat das ja sozusagen auch etwas sehr erfreuliches für einen in dem Moment.
Genau, ich glaube das ist auch das, weshalb die Leute da hingehen. Was noch wichtig ist, das haben aber die allermeisten Science-Slamer glücklicherweise begriffen, ist halt kein Text auf den Folien und zu verstehen, dass die Folie eine Illustration ist für den Vortrag.
Und kein Teleprompter.
Kein Teleprompter. Das lässt auch ein bisschen zu wünschen übrig, oft sehen die Leute die Folie und überlegen dann, was sie eigentlich nochmal sagen wollen, dann noch ein paar Sekunden Verzögerung.
Ah die Folie, die habe ich doch schonmal gesehen.
Ja, also man kann auch sagen, das ist eigentlich wie so ein Bilderbuch. Das Bild ist immer an der Stelle zu dem was man gerade erzählt. Oft ergibt sich ja auch durch das Zusammenspiel von Bild und gesprochenem Wort der Witz. Und ganz wichtig daran ist, dass man halt den Vortrag auswendig kann und weiß, welche Folie jetzt kommt als nächstes. Und das ist zack zack zack. Dass es einfach sitzt. Das Timing ist alles, also aufs Timing kommt es echt an.
Zehn Minuten ist eine ganz Interessante Maßeinheit. Es gibt noch eine andere, wirst du vielleicht kennen, 6:40 Minuten, das ist das Zeitmaß von Pecha Kucha, je nachdem wie man das gerne aussprechen möchte, da schon mal mit geliebäugelt? Also zur Erläuterung, das ist ja quasi ein Vortragsrahmen, in dem man mit 20 Bildern arbeitet, die jeweils 20 Sekunden automatisch angezeigt werden, das heißt man hat das Fortschreiten der Slides nicht mehr in der Hand, sondern es ist quasi von der Zeit her vorgegeben und läuft automatisch ab und dazu muss man dann sozusagen sein Feuer entfalten. Und in der Regel sind es dann auch eher Fotos als Slides im eigentlichen Sinne. Hat das schonmal jemand mit reingetragen?
…
Weil ich finde, das hat auch eine Menge Feuer. Also sozusagen man merkt richtig, wie man so als Vortragender, ich habe das auch selber mal gemacht, wenn man in so einem  vorgegebenen Zeittakt liefern muss, das ist cracy.
Ich glaube ich habe da, also ich habe auch mehrere Pecha Kucha Nights schon selbst mit erlebt. Ich finde das so ein bisschen beliebig. Also diese Vorgabe, wo man sich fragt, warum? Und ich finde auch beim Vortrag jetzt form follows function und nicht andersrum. Ich finde es irgendwie merkwürdig, so eine Form so ganz strikt vorzugeben. Und auch, dass die Themen so sehr frei sind. Die Leute dürfen ja eigentlich über alles reden was sie machen. Ach da hat mir das halt an den Pecha Kucha Nights, an denen ich so dabei war, nicht so gefallen, dass es oft so eine Werbeveranstaltung war, dass halt wirklich alle Leute nur ihre nicht unbedingt Unternehmen, aber so Plattformen und so vorgestellt haben. Und gesagt haben, hier ihr könnt mitarbeiten, hier ihr könnt euch hier eintragen, hier bestellt ihr unseren Newslettern, dass es sich oft so häufte.
Habe ich so nicht mitbekommen. Ich war auf einer interessanteren …
Ich war schon auf mehreren, die so waren, so von wegen, guck mal was wir tolles machen. das machen natürlich die Science-Slamer ein Stück weit auch, aber da hat es so einen Kern …
Ja gut, aber wenn es nicht irgendwie um Newsletter geht, sondern wenn man bei Wissenschaft bleibt, finde ich das durchaus ein unterhaltsames Format und es ist sozusagen ja auch nochmal eine ganz andere Beschränkung und gerade die Beschränkung. Also hier ist es ja schon, 10 Minuten ist schon eine enorme Beschränkung für komplexe Sachverhalte. Wenn man dann nochmal auf 6:40 Minuten runtergeht, dann wird es ja schon fast apokalyptisch und wenn man dann sozusagen noch nicht mal die Dauer eines Slides kontrollieren kann. Meine Erfahrung war nur, das setzt dann einfach auch ganz andere Präsentationsskills wiederum frei, die man einfach braucht, um den Flow in dem Moment überhaupt noch gestalten zu können. Naja ich wollte das nur mal kurz einwerfen, weil diese Kurzpräsentationen scheinen auch so ein bisschen Kultur zu haben, so seit  10-20 Jahren und das drückt sich halt unter anderem auch darin aus.
Das glaube ich auch. Ich finde Pecha Kucha irgendwie überreguliert. Ich finde 10 Minuten ist schon wirklich eine starke Ansage, das weiß ich selbst. Aber in den 10 Minuten dürfen sie ja machen was sie wollen.
Gut beim Slam kommt natürlich dann ja auch die Bühne selbst mit ins Spiel, das ist nicht nur der Beamer, sondern es sind auch die Dinge, die dort gegebenenfalls noch gezeigt werden. Sachen, die man in die Hand nimmt etc. Das ist sicherlich dann wiederum ein Charakteristikum des Spams. Wenn man jetzt nochmal so ein bisschen an den Anfang springt und diese eigentliche Frage der Wissenschaftskommunikation, wir haben jetzt sozusagen den Science-Slam einfach als Auftrag auch mal interpretiert. Wir leben ja jetzt so ein bisschen in so einer Zeit der, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Historiker diese Zeit dann irgendwann mal nennen werden, aber es scheint so eine Begeisterung für Faktenfreiheit und wir glauben jetzt einfach mal an irgendwas zu geben. Das sehen wir in der Politik, wo faktenfrei kommuniziert wird.
Aber wir sehen auch gerade so im Netz so eine merkwürdige Mischung aus Hasskultur und Glaubenskriegen im Bezug auf fast alles. Ob es gesellschaftliche Diskurse aller Art werden herangezogen. Aber es betrifft ja auch die Wissenschaft sehr stark. Welche Rolle würdest du da den Slums an der Stelle zuordnen und wie begegnet ihr dem?
Also ich glaube, die Slams sind halt eine Möglichkeit, die echte Wissenschaft, also die hochschulangebundene und die Peer-reviewte Wissenschaft, die ich auch überhaupt nicht verkläre, also ich weiß, dass es da durchaus auch Probleme gibt, die unters Volk zu bringen. Und vielleicht auch wissenschaftliches Denken den Leuten näher zu bringen. Was man bei vielen anderen Wissenschaftskommunikationsformaten nicht so hat. Also wenn wir über Wissenschaft in der Zeitung lesen, dann ist das, wen ein Paper schon veröffentlicht wurde und da halt entsprechende mehrere Leute irgendwie draufstehen, die das zusammen geschrieben haben und jemand das begutachtet hat und für veröffentlichungswürdig erachtet. Und dann gibt die Pressestelle was dazu raus und dann steht es erst in der Zeitung und es steht, Wissenschaftler haben rausgefunden, dass . Und das ist sozusagen da kann man nicht mehr dran rütteln und das ist alles ganz fest.
Und beim Science-Slam gib es halt die Möglichkeit zu sagen, okay das hier ist jetzt meine Forschung der letzten drei Jahre und die ersten 2,5 Jahre sind das und das und nach 2,5 Jahren hatte ich das und das Ergebnis und konnte alles in die Tonne treten und konnte überlegen, was ich jetzt damit mache. Und das ist was, das kennt jeder Wissenschaftler, das ist jedem schonmal so gegangen, dass man irgendwie auf einer falschen Fährte war oder dass man eine wunderbare Theorie im Kopf hatte und die hat sich dann aber nicht bestätigt. Und das kann man halt beim Science-Slam sozusagen diesen Prozess kann man beim Science-Slam auch mit abbilden.
Weil es eher eine prozessorientierte Beschreibung ist als eine ergebnisorientierte Beschreibung.
Ja genau. Ich sage auch immer, die Leute präsentieren nicht ihre Forschungsergebnisse, sondern ihre Forschungsprojekte. Und sie sagen, das ist so und so und so und ach ich hatte einen Science-Slamer, der hat gesagt, ich habe eine Sonde gebaut, musste ich mir ganz viele Sachen selber bestellen und zusammenbasteln, die Lichtemission oder Lichtblitze, mit denen sich Krill verständigt in norwegischen Fjorden, mit denen ich dieses Licht messen konnte. Und dann habe ich irgendwie in 150 Meter Tiefe meine Sonde gehabt und diese minikleinen Lichtblitze aufgenommen und versucht, mir da einen Reim drauf zu machen und dann kommt so ein blödes Motorboot und hackt mir das Kabel ab und das ist ein Jahr Bastelarbeit, liegen unten in so einem Fjord. Und das liest man halt sonst nicht. Das kriegt man sonst nicht mit, dass Wissenschaftler so was machen.
Aber was für eine tolle Story, so traurig sie jetzt ist.
Ja oder Leute, die halt dann auch Bilder zeigen, wie sie irgendwo im Regenwald sind und alles ist voller Schlamm und genau. Man findet noch nicht mal mehr ein Platz, wo man irgendwas zum Trocknen aufhängen kann, weil alles nur regnerisch ist. Wie sie von Mücken zerstochen werden oder dass Leute auch erzählen, ich meine was haben wir denn von den Teilchenbeschleunigern, was erfahren wir denn von denen wirklich? Selten, das ist ja passiert, dass das Higgs-Boson entdeckt wurde, dass da was richtig großes bei rumkommt. Aber dass da tausende von Menschen irgendwo im Keller sitzen und Pizza essen, das erzählen die Leute halt nur beim Science-Slam. Dieses tägliche Leben und auch was für ein winzig kleines Rad man da im Getriebe ist, und wie unbeschreiblich winzig der eigene Beitrag ist und dass man es trotzdem gut findet, das zu machen. Dass man trotzdem da stundenlang und am Wochenende und für wenig Geld und mit total unsicherer Zukunft trotzdem sich entscheidet, daran mit zu forschen. Das kann man halt beim Science-Slam gut transportieren.
Aber sind denn so die ganzen pseudowissenschaftlichen Menschen, die so unterwegs sind. Ich weiß nicht spiegelt sich das im Science-Slam wieder? Gibt es da auch so Leute, die da drauf einhacken? Versteht ihr sozusagen den Slam als Teil dieser Auseinandersetzung, auch mit dieser Bewegung, sozusagen mit Nichtwissen oder falschem Wissen zu argumentieren?
Ich glaube so richtig ansprechen tut es kaum jemand auf der Bühne, das ist relativ selten auch. Ab und zu kommen da irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien zur Sprache oder die schon erwähnten Teilchenphysiker, die denken, irgendwie – was hatte man nochmal für Befürchtungen am CERN, dass ein schwarzes Loch entsteht und wir da alle drin verschwinden.
Ach so dass die ganze Erde verschwindet.
So was wir dann mal angesprochen oder dass irgendwelche Asteroiden uns demnächst hier auslöschen werden. Aber so eine ganz zentrale Rolle spielt es eigentlich nicht. Ich glaube, bei vielen Wissenschaftlern, die da auf der Bühne sind, die sind ja tagtäglich mit ihren anderen Wissenschaftlern zusammen, die merken glaube ich oft auch gar nicht, was für ein großes Problem das ist, diese Pseudowissenschaften. Dass so die Leute auf der Straße oft an absurde Sachen glauben.
Das bringt uns so ein bisschen zum zweiten Teil auch deiner Aktivität. Weil neben dieser Science-Slam Organisationstätigkeit hast du ja noch einen anderen Hut, den du mit dir herumträgst. Nämlich die Aktivität im Rahmen der GWUP. Der oh Gott, jetzt habe ich wieder den Namen nicht parat.
Die Gesellschaft zur wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung von Parawissenschaften.
Genau die, die meinte ich. Die Parawissenschaften. Also Wissenschaften, die irgendwie eigentlich keine sind.
Genau. Sachen oder Leute, die ihren Theorien einen wissenschaftlichen Anspruch geben oder Anstrich geben, aber nicht wissenschaftlich sind. Und auch mit der Wissenschaft nicht in Einklang zu bringen sind.
Die GWUP Ist ja jetzt nichts neues. Also das gibt es ja schon relativ lange, ich glaube 87 gegründet. Relativ groß angewachsen, 1300 Mitglieder. Wir muss man sich diese Organisation vorstellen? Was für Leute sind da drin aktiv, was ist das Ziel der GWUP?
Also die Organisation ist so, wir haben Mitglieder in Deutschland, Österreich und der Schweiz, also wir decken so den ganzen deutschsprachigen Raum ab mit diesen inzwischen glaube ich 1400 Mitgliedern sogar. Was sind da für Leute drin? Es sind Wissenschaftler und Leute, die sich für Wissenschaft interessieren, aber längst nicht alle haben wirklich einen wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund. Und ich glaube es sind Leute, also so wie es bei mir auch gelaufen ist, die irgendwie gedacht haben, naja es gibt halt so ein paar Esoteriker, es gibt Leute, die nehmen hier homöopathische Mittelchen für alles mögliche. Es gibt Leute, die glaube, dass wenn sie Metallschrauben in ihrem Bett haben, dass sie dann schlechter schlafen, als wenn das mit Holzdübeln zusammengehalten wird. Und man dachte immer, man kann die ignorieren und irgendwann merkt man, das sind echt viele da draußen, die so denken und sich dann freut, dass es einen Verein gibt mit Gleichdenkenden.
Gleichgesinnten. Dass man da hingehen kann und sagen, was die Leute sich alles ausdenken und diese Spinner und sich auch mit denen so ein bisschen auch darüber amüsieren kann, auf jeden Fall. Weil es ist ja wirklich auch sehr kreativ, was sich Esoteriker immer ausdenken. Die aber halt auch sagen, ey wir wollen dem nicht nur hilflos zusehen, wir möchten irgendwas tun dagegen, wir möchten jetzt mit aufklären. Wir möchten mit versuchen, Leute zu erreichen und denen vielleicht auch das wissenschaftlich kritische Denken zu vermitteln und denen Hilfsmittel an die Hand zu geben, wie sie rausfinden können, ob Sachen stimmen oder nicht stimmen oder nicht stimmen können.
Wenn du sagst, es sind ja echt viele, wie muss man sich dieses Phänomen vorstellen?
Wie muss man sich das Phänomen vorstellen.
Was spielt sich da gerade ab?
Was großen Zulauf hat sind halt diese sogenannten alternativen Therapieformen oder diese Alternativmedizin. Man kriegt ja in jeder Apotheke diese Globoli, diese Zuckerkügelchen, ohne jeglichen Wirkstoff und das wird auch viel genommen. Und die Apotheker verkaufen das ja auch. Das machen Leute. Dann was ich für ein großes Problem habe, was glaube ich in den USA ein größeres Problem ist, aber was hier auch wirklich verbreitet ist, sind Leute, die denken, dass Impfungen nicht wirksam sind oder sogar schaden, halt sogenannte Impfgegner. Oder die sogar denken, es gäbe keine Viren und das wäre alles eine große Verschwörung. Also das sind halt die Leute, die wirklich auch die Gesundheit andere Leute auch damit aufs Spiel setzen. Ja.
Ich meine, gibt es irgendwelche quantitativen Erfassungen dieses Problems? Also ich meine so, es gibt Leute da draußen, ja klar so. Man hat manchmal das Gefühl, es könnten auch viele sein, aber was weiß ich, vielleicht ist es ja die Mehrheit der Gesellschaft, die mittlerweile in diese Richtung denkt. Hat jemand mal versucht, das zu fassen?
Das ist schwer, auch darüber Zahlen zu bekommen. Auch darüber, ob es jetzt viel mehr geworden ist oder weniger. Es gibt da Schätzungen. Ich habe da jetzt auch keine Zahl parat. ich weiß, ich glaube die Homöopathieindustrie setzt ungefähr eine halbe Milliarde Euro um im Jahr in Deutschland. Also 500.000 Millionen, sind schon ein paar Euro von jedem.
Das ist eine Menge Geld für ein bisschen Zucker und für null Forschung.
Das ist eine Menge Geld für ein bisschen Zucker.
Ja.
Keine Entwicklungskosten. Wir denken uns was aus, verdünnen das und verkaufen das für viel Geld.
Machen die das eigentlich wirklich? Ich meine, gibt es da Einblicke in diese Welt? Also glauben die da dran?
Also … ich möchte ungern Leuten unterstellen, dass sie das verkaufen wirklich aus reiner … Also mit der festen Überzeugung, dass das alles Quatsch ist. Also das möchte ich niemandem unterstellen. Ich glaube, dass viele Leute schon daran glauben. Viele Leute glaube ich, die da näher mit zu tun haben, auch Apotheker, die sagen, okay die Studienlage ist eine Katastrophe. Es gibt keine Studien, die bestätigen, dass halt ein homöopathisches Mittel, in dem die Substanz so verdünnt ist, dass da kein Molekül mehr von enthalten ist, dass das besser wirkt als ein Placebo. Aber es wirkt ja als Placebo. Und es wirkt als Placebo sehr gut, der ist sehr stark dieser Effekt. Und die denken halt dann so, ja warum dann eigentlich nicht? Ich glaube, diese Einstellung haben viele Menschen. Und ich glaube aber von den Konsumenten, da sind ganz viele der Überzeugung, dass das wirkt.
Aber der Placebo-Effekt, der ist total stark. Es gibt ganz viel, was da auch reinspielt, dass das wirkt. Einmal auch, dass man einem Heilpraktiker Geld geben muss in bar. Also wenn jemand 120 Euro bezahlt dafür, dass er beim Heilpraktiker war und der sagt, nimm das und das, dann wirkt das besser.
Dann muss es ja wirken.
Ja es gibt auch Studien, wenn du Geld ausgibst, dann hast du hinterher leichter das Gefühl, dass es dir besser geht.
Weil man nicht zugeben will, dass man sozusagen eine Ausgabe für nichts gemacht hat?
Ich glaube die Psyche ist zu komplex, um das so zu sagen. Zu sagen, dass man es nicht zugeben will. Ich glaube das ist einfach so ein Gefühl, aber ja klar, im Prinzip ist es das.
Ja. Ich würde jetzt gerne nochmal so ein bisschen weg von dieser konkreten Homöopathie, Alternativmedizin, das ist ja sozusagen auch nur ein Feld, was die GWUP sich sozusagen widmet. Also früher, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, hat man sich halt auch mal gerne mit diesen reinen Esoterikern und sonstigen Zauberkünstlern und Glasbeschwörern und Schwebenlassern viel auch auseinandergesetzt, weil das ja immer so eine ganz ganz plastische und teilweise sehr unterhaltsame Form war, wo man eben einfach widerlegen kann bzw. die Unmöglichkeit des Beweises sozusagen auch einfordert. Es gibt diesen James Randi, der ja Wissenschaftler, aber auch irgendwie Zauberkünstler glaube ich war, der lebt ja noch. Und der hat diesen Preis ausgesetzt, dass er glaube eine Million Dollar zahlen würde, wer ihm auch immer ein paranormales Phänomen auch tatsächlich mal beweisen kann. Sind viele dran gescheitert, also alle eigentlich.
Ja, ich glaube die haben 400 Leute getestet oder so. Paranormale Fähigkeiten wollten sie beweisen. Also sollten die Leute beweisen. Und da es um eine Million Dollar ging, waren die Leute auch sehr kreativ, ihn zu bescheißen. Also da gab es so Sachen, er hat eine Sache mir erzählt, dass jemand mit einem Pendel rausfinden wollte, wo sie etwas verstecken, einen Gegenstand verstecken. Und dann sind die losgefahren, um den Gegenstand zu verstecken auf dem platten Land und dann haben sie halt gemerkt, dass ihnen ein Auto folgt, dann hatten die halt ihre Kompagnons da vor die Tür gesetzt, gesagt, spionier mal aus, wo die das hin tun.
Aber das sind so diese unterhaltsamen Highlights. Aber man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, oder ich habe das jetzt mal zumindest oder deklarier das mal so, dass dieses sich nicht an Fakten orientieren irgendwie generell hoffähig wird. Man merkt das auch in dieser Klimadebatte, wo ja dann auch so ein bisschen dieses Unwort geprägt wurde des Klimaskeptikers, das jetzt so ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung führt, weil ja eigentlich bis dahin das Wort Skeptiker genau eben für die skeptische Bewegung der Wissenschaft, die sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, wie würdest du es definieren? Also Skepsis wem gegenüber ausdrückt?
Ich glaube so das kritische Denken, wenn man was hört, was einem komisch vorkommt, erst mal darüber nachzudenken. Und auch Sachen, die einem selbst als selbstverständlich oder geläufig erscheinen, dann da einfach auch mal einen Schritt zurückzutreten und zu sagen, kann das eigentlich sein? Kommt das eigentlich so hin? passt das zu den anderen Erkenntnissen, die wir haben? das ist dieses Skeptikertum ursprünglich. Mit dem Klimaskeptikern das stimmt, da haben wir einfach ein großes semantisches Schlamassel, dass die sich so nennen. Aber Klima ist zum Beispiel auch ein Thema, mit dem wir uns beschäftigen. Naja es gibt halt auch so eine paar auch aktuellere Themen, die ein bisschen größer sind und die halt auch oft von Ideologien geleitet sind und bewertet sind. Wie zum Beispiel der Klimawandel. Ich meine, wenn ich da nicht dran glaube, dann kann ich das Fenster aufmachen und die Heizung an und so viel Autofahren wie ich will und das ist für den einzelnen so erst mal ganz angenehm, nicht daran zu glauben, dass der Klimawandel menschengemacht ist.
Und dass man dazu was beitragen kann, den zu stoppen oder zu begrenzen. zu den Fakten nochmal, ich glaube, und dass die Leute den Fakten keine Bedeutung mehr beimessen, bzw. dass die Leute Sachen für Fakten halten, die im wissenschaftlichen Sinne keine sind, ich glaube ja das liegt am Internet, das böse böse Internet hat das gemacht. Ich glaube, dass das ganz viele Leute sind, die vielleicht auch ein bisschen fortgeschrittenes Alter haben. Also sagen wir mal so 30-40-50-60. Also die ganz jungen Leute eher nicht. Leute sind, die damit aufgewachsen sind, dass wenn was in der Zeitung steht, dann stimmt das. Die sozusagen alles was gedruckt ist oder was geschrieben ist, ist für die ein Stück weit richtig. Das war ja auch bis Mitte der 90er Jahre so.
Dass sozusagen von allem, was man irgendwo gedruckt gesehen hat, das war eine relativ verlässliche Quelle im Vergleich zu heute.
Heute schauen sie in die Facebookzeitung und da steht es ja dann auch.
Genau und habe ich im Internet gelesen. Und irgendjemand schreibt, Institut für so und so und schreibt da drauf, das und das und das ist so und dann lesen das die Leute und sehen das Wort Institut, was nicht geschützt ist, jeder kann alles Institut nennen. Und denkt so, das stimmt, weil das stand da.
Ja Institut für Wahrheit und besondere Erkenntnis.
Genau Institut für wie es wirklich ist ja.
Ist das dann sozusagen nur ein vorübergehendes Phänomen, in dem wir uns jetzt gerade befinden? Ist das eine reine Frage der Annäherung an ein weltveränderndes Universalmedium? Und ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis sich das irgendwie herauswächst? Oder kommt hier nicht irgendwas zum Ausdruck in besonders starker Form, was an sich breit angelegt ist? Ich meine, wir haben ja dann, ich weiß nicht, wie breit wir jetzt das Thema spreizen wollen, aber im Prinzip ist es ja auch so ein bisschen die wissenschaftliche Sicht auf die Welt, die versucht durch einen stark definierten Informationsdiskurs sich einer Wahrheit anzunähern, die eben weitestgehend oder so weit es sich eben realisieren lässt, auf Fakten basiert. Und die ja in zunehmendem Maße zu einem Weltbild führt, was sich ja auch beweisen lässt in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ja es gibt viele Annahmen und Erkenntnisse, und dadurch dass man in der Lage ist, Roboter auf dem Mars durch die Gegend fahren zu lassen, sind einfach viele von diesen Dingen bewiesen, weil wäre es nicht so gewesen, wäre das Ding wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal dort angekommen. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir große Teile der Weltbevölkerung, die einfach an Geister glaubt sozusagen, die also Götter hinter dem Entstehen des Planeten sehen und die halt in alles irgendwie hereinwirken und denen man Botschaften in Form von Gebeten zusenden muss, damit das richtige passiert. Spaltet sich da irgendwie die Gesellschaft in zwei Teile? War das schon immer so? Oder gibt es eigentlich auch Grund für Optimismus?
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Das war jetzt auch so viel auf einmal. Also mit den Robotern, die auf dem Mars rumfahren. Wissen wir, ob sie das tun, oder ist das nur vor einem Studio gefaket? Da kann man schon anfangen. Also das als Beweis heranzuziehen, da wird man so einen Hardcore-Verschwörungstheoretiker überhaupt nicht mit überzeugen.
Ja okay, aber ich glaube so mit Spiegel auf dem Mond kann man schon ganz gut argumentieren.
Ja, also ich finde das ja sowieso. Ich glaube, dass das Interesse an Wissenschaft auch mit so einem Fortschritt der Technik wächst. Dass die Leute irgendwie merken, dass es cool ist, dass wir jetzt irgendwie ständig und überall ins Internet können und so, dass die Leute schon merken, da ist Forschung drin in diesen neuen Technologien oder nicht mehr so neuen Technologien. Das hat was, weil es führt wirklich zu diesen Ergebnissen, von denen wir vor zwei Generationen, also an die wir noch nicht mal gedacht haben vor zwei Generationen. ob es jetzt mehr Leute gibt, die an absurde Sachen glauben, ich weiß es nicht. ich meine, ich weiß nicht genau wie das vor 30-40-50 Jahren war. Da war es auch schon so, dass die Leute  an Ufos geglaubt haben und dass Ufos gesichtet wurden. Und dass man sich solche Geschichten erzählt hat und auch dass man solche Bücher geschrieben hat.
Also irgendwie Erich von Däniken ist ja auch irgendwie schon Jahrzehnte alt. Da haben die Leute auch daran, also Bermudadreieck und solche Sachen sind halt alt. Und die GWUP hat sich übrigens auch gegründet als Reaktion auf Uri Geller.
Den Gabelverbieger?
Den Gabelverbieger. Ja der war ja auch Ende der 80er Jahre. da haben ja auch wahnsinnig viele Leute dran geglaubt, dass der das wirklich kann mit telepathischen Kräften.
Konnte er nicht?
Tja wir wissen es nicht. Wir sind ja ergebnisoffen als Wissenschaftler.
Er konnte es zumindest bisher noch nicht beweisen.
Er konnte es nicht beweisen und James Randi, den du ja schon erwähnt hattest, hat ihn auch aufs übelste Auflaufen lassen beim Fernsehen.
Sehr sehenswerter Clip.
Ich bin irgendwie raus, ich weiß nicht, was ich eben gesagt habe.
Ich wollt so ein bisschen vielleicht ins Philosophische, jetzt doch mal in die Geisteswissenschaft vielleicht abdrängen und einfach so ein bisschen versuchen zu verorten. Weil wenn man, wie wir beide ja auch, sagen wir mal der Wissenschaft an sich positiv gegenüber steht und auch für sich selber klar herleiten kann, alles was wir sozusagen heutzutage hier tun, einschließlich der Aufzeichnung dieses Podcasts, ist einfach Ergebnis wissenschaftlicher Forschung über hunderte von Jahren. Die gesamte Zivilisation, die gebauten Häuser, nicht nur unbedingt die Raumschiffe, die immer gleich ins Ferne ziehen, sondern das ganz konkrete, Plastikmaterialien, egal was, nichts wäre ohne Wissenschaft überhaupt da. Strom nicht, alles nicht.
Genau, wenn nicht jemand rausgefunden hätte, dass es Mikroorganismen gibt, was ein ganz ganz harter und steiniger Weg war, das rauszufinden, hätten wir jetzt kein sauberes Trinkwasser. Weil das müssen wir ja wissen, um diese Versorgung mit dem im allergrundlegendsten sicherzustellen.
Was kann man dazu beitragen, wie bildet sich das vielleicht auch in der GWUP ab? Wie kriegt man diesen Diskurs wieder in den Griff?
Ich glaube, man muss sich vor allen Dingen Gehör verschaffen. Man muss also, wie wir jetzt auch, möglichst viel öffentlich über solche Themen reden. Man muss auch über Wissenschaft reden, was Wissenschaft kann, dass Wissenschaft, wie ich eben schon sagte, auch ein Prozess ist, weil das ist ja was, was einem die Gegenseite, also die Pseudowissenschaften oft vorhalten. Von wegen, ihr habt doch auch lange gedacht, das wäre so und so und dann hat sich hinterher rausgestellt, das war gar nicht so. Und dann zu sagen, ja das gehört dazu. Wir stellen uns aber immer wieder in Frage, und wir erneuern uns und wir überprüfen das. Es ist halt nicht so, wie Beispiel Homöopathie, dass es seit 200 Jahren total unverändert ist und dass sich da gar nichts bewegt, weil sich auch nichts bewegen kann. Weil es einfach nur eine Theorie ist, die in sich selbst sich bestätigt.
Ja und da diese ganzen Pseudowissenschaften ja auch ihre Interessen vertreten und auch sehr häufig irgendwelche Dinge verkaufen wollen etc. und deshalb auch entsprechend Alarm machen. Also man findet ja auf YouTube unfassbar viel Material von Leuten, die einem die absurdesten Dinge erzählen, Verschwörungstheorien und ähnliche Dinge. Da muss man als Wissenschaftler glaube ich sich das klar machen und sagen, wenn wir uns nicht hinstellen und sagen, Beispiel impfen ist gut, impfen schützt vor Krankheiten, ja impfen tut weh, man sticht ein gesundes Kind und das fällt niemandem leicht, aber wir haben die und die Erfolge. Die Masern haben wir kaum noch, wir haben praktisch keine Kinderlähmung mehr auf der Welt und so zu sagen, wir haben die Erfolge. Das muss man halt machen, man kann das nicht voraussetzen, dass die Leute das wissen.
Dann googeln die nach impfen und dann finden die unter den ersten zehn Treffern acht Seiten, die einem Seiten, nein impfen brauchen wir nicht, ist gefährlich. Und deshalb muss man zusehen, dass man da unter die ersten Treffer kommt und sagt, nein das ist gut und das funktioniert so und so und das sind die Erfolge und das habt ihr der Wissenschaft zu verdanken. Und diese antiwissenschaftliche Einstellung, man sieht auch, dass die mit der Zeit gehen und dass die die Wissenschaft ja auch nicht missen möchten. Am Anfang war es ja noch so, vor 15 Jahren, da haben die Leute gesagt, Handys sind schädlich, Handys strahlen ganz doll und das ist ganz ungesund und davon, die moderaten Leute haben gesagt, davon kriegen wir Gehirntumore und die Hardcoreleute haben gesagt, damit werden wir ferngesteuert. Und jetzt haben die Leute aber mitbekommen, dass ein Handy gar nicht so unpraktisch zu haben ist und jetzt fokussieren sie sich halt auf die Handymasten, die sind ja böse.
Weil ein Handy hat dann jeder, und die machen das dann nachts aus, wenn sie es gerade nicht brauchen. Aber ich meine, ohne Handy kann man halt nicht mehr leben oder es würde das Leben schon stark einschränken, das will man ja auch nicht, deshalb fokussieren die sich jetzt gerade auf die Handymasten. Das wird bei denen auch noch durchdringen, dass die Handys nur funktionieren, wenn die Handymasten auch an sind, aber da warten wir noch ein bisschen drauf, der Groschen fällt da nicht so schnell. Oder ja Leute, die ihre Kinder nicht impfen lassen und wenn es Masern hat, bringen sie es natürlich trotzdem ins Krankenhaus und vertrauen da auf die Medizin, die sie vorher wirklcih …
Oder im schlimmsten Fall noch nicht mal das. Gibt ja auch etwas tragische Fälle, wo dann halt auch sozusagen die Behandlung auch noch komplett abgelehnt wird.
Das gibt es, aber ich glaube, das sind wirklich wenige Fälle. Ich glaube, es gibt viele Fälle von Leuten, die ihre Kinder nicht impfen lassen und dann wenn es wirklich hart auf hart kommt sagen, okay jetzt kann nur so ein Hightech-Krankenhaus helfen.
Ja ich meine, ich glaube auch nicht, dass das so ein unumkehrbarer Prozess ist. Also gerade Masern ein schönes Thema. Da gab es ja dann jüngst, also tatsächlich einen relativ nennenswerten Ausbruch in Berlin Prenzlauer Berg, der ja auch sehr verschrien ist und sehr mit Homöopathen und Alternativmedizinern durchsetzte Region. Eine in meinem Augen auch etwas absurde Mischung, weil in diesem Gebiet auch ein extrem hoher Anteil von akademisch ausgebildeten Menschen ist, der jetzt nicht so für prekäres Leben und prekäre Bildung bekannt ist, sondern ganz im Gegenteil. Leute, die eigentlich das Rüstzeug haben sollten für klare Erkenntnisse. die dann aber trotzdem in irgendeiner Form dem auf den Leim gegangen ist, bis sie eben das Impfsystem soweit geschwächt haben, dass Masern sich tatsächlich ausbreiten konnten. Bis es halt zum extremen Fall kam mit einem …
Einem toten Kind ja.
Einem toten Kind und ein paar Infektionen noch, wo es nicht zum Tode kam. Binnen eines Jahres hat sich die Impfsituation da jetzt verbessert. Also es ist sozusagen schon umkehrbar, die Frage ist nur, wie erreicht man jetzt diese Gruppen? Insbesondere die gebildeteren Gruppen. Haben wir jetzt vielleicht mit einem Versäumnis auch zu tun, was ausgebügelt muss? Macht die Wissenschaft was falsch?
Also ich glaube, sie ist grundsätzlich zu ruhig. Sie kümmert sich innerhalb von ihrer Community um die Ergebnisse, aber vielen Wissenschaftlern ist einfach nicht bewusst genug, dass sie das auch nach außen tragen müssen. Und dass sie sich auch selber erklären müssen.
Echokammer?
Man ist so in seinem eigenen Ding, man hört sein eigenes Echo die ganze Zeit und denkt sich, wieso es reden doch alle davon?
Ja, genau.
Genau, und dann glaube ich aber auch, dass es auch wirklich ein Wohlstandsproblem ist, wie du eben schon gesagt hast. Also die Leute, die es sich leisten können, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, die machen sich dann darüber Gedanken. Wenn jemand nicht weiß, ob er die 12 Euro für einen Schulausflug irgendwie zusammensparen kann, die Leute haben einfach keine Zeit und wirklich dringendere Probleme, als sich über solchen Quatsch Gedanken zu machen. Ich glaube, dass es daran liegt, dass es oft so diese Akademikerkreise sind, die der Alternativmedizin anhängen und ihre Kinder nicht impfen lassen.
Aber ist doch vollkommen absurd?
Ja es ist vollkommen absurd. Ich habe da auch keine Antwort drauf, warum das so ist. Ich glaube die haben zu viel Zeit. Also die hängen abends im Internet rum und die sind vielleicht auch weniger, ich sage jetzt mal, obrigkeitshörig. Also ich glaube niedrigere soziale Schichten, wenn der Arzt sagt, das ist gut, dann glauben die dem Arzt und die stellen halt nicht so alles in Frage, wie Akademiker das dann leichter machen.
Die das auch selber im Internet nochmal nachgeschlagen haben und so?
Genau. Ich gucke mir das nochmal selber an und was mein Hausarzt oder Kinderarzt, der sieben Jahre Studium und fünf Jahre Facharzt hinter sich hat, was der sagt, ach das habe ich mir auch heute Abend schon angelesen.
Da reden wir ja aber eigentlich von einer Generation, die sozusagen mit dem Netz aber noch nicht gor geworden ist, sondern die sozusagen jetzt nur die Auswirkung davon mitbekommt.
Ja genau. Und halt auch von Leuten, die nicht Quellen beurteilen können im Internet. Und die nicht verstanden haben, dass jeder alles schreiben kann. Und dass die Leute mit den abseitigeren Theorien oft diejenigen sind, die mehr schreiben.
Welche Berührungspunkte hat denn die GWUP jetzt auch als Organisation mit der Religion so? Das ist ja dann sozusagen auch nochmal so ein Masterfeld, wo das ergebnistheoretisch anders ist.
Das ist ein Masterfeld das stimmt. Wir halten uns da relativ raus. Weil wir uns auf Aussagen fokussieren, die widerlegbar sind. Wenn jemand eine nicht falsifizierbare Aussage macht, dann können wir das auch nicht testen. Also es heißt ja wissenschaftliche Untersuchung von Parawissenschaften. Wenn jemand sagt, es gibt Gott, dann können wir das nicht testen. Wenn jemand sagt, die Erde ist 5000 Jahre alt und die Dinosaurier wurden als Fossilien schon da hingelegt, die sind hier nie rumgelaufen, dann ist das was, was wir testen können mit wissenschaftlichen Methoden. Also diese Kreationisten, die diese Thesen verbreiten. Also da können wir sagen, hier das ist ein Feld für uns, ein Betätigungsfeld. Wenn jemand sagt, es gibt Gott und der hat die Erde erschaffen, was sollen wir da machen, das können wir nicht überprüfen und nicht widerlegen. Und deshalb halten wir uns da raus.
Ja gut, aber vielleicht geht die Reaktion ja auch in die andere Richtung, dass es sozusagen auch ein Echo gibt aus solchen Kreisen. Auf diese wissenschaftliche Arbeit und dieses faktenorientierte. Weil sowohl jetzt, weiß ich nicht, ob ich das jetzt schon mit den Science-Slams zusammenbringen kann, aber sowohl die GWUP als eben auch andere Aktivitäten, wie der Science-Slam, versuchen ja, das Modell wissenschaftliche erkenntnisorientierte Arbeit und faktenbasierte Beobachtung des Planeten zu verbreiten. Das sozusagen als Modell auch populär zu machen und zu sagen, hier das geht, das kann man machen. Man kann dumme Aussagen im Netz oder sonst wo aus irgendwelchen Freundeskreisen kann man irgendwie überprüfen, so macht man das und man kann dabei auch noch Spaß haben. In dem Moment, wo es an Glauben herangeht, wird es halt immer so ein bisschen schwierig, weil ja diese Glaubensmodelle naja eben auf, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das so ist, und Überprüfung ist da sozusagen kein Teil davon.
Aber vielleicht gibt es aj auch Leute aus diesem religiösen Bereich, die in irgendeiner Form das auch zusammengeführt bekommen.
Da gibt es sogar relativ viele. Also es gibt sogar wirklich skeptische Gläubige. Also Leute, die an einen christlichen Gott glauben und trotzdem sehr skeptisch Aussagen, die über die Welt getroffen werden, gegenüber treten. Also es gibt ja auch leider nur noch von den Kirchen Sektenbeauftragte, die sich mit solchen Themen auseinandersetzen. Und die einfach genau die gleichen Positionen vertreten wie ich, nur dass die halt noch glauben, dass es einen Gott gibt, was ich nicht tue.
Aber die jetzt auch in der ganzen Pseudowissenschaft dann auch eine Gefahr sind.
Ja genau auf jeden Fall. ich meine das gräbt ihnen natürlich auch ein bisschen was ab. Es gibt aj auch viele so an Scharmanismus und an was Leute jetzt inzwischen heutzutage hier denken, glauben zu müssen. Da laufen natürlich der Kirche auch noch ein paar Leute weg. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass der einzige Beweggrund ist, sondern die Kirche weiß auch, dass man sich da auch wirklich in eine psychische Abhängigkeit bringen kann, es gibt ja Leute, die befragen vor jeder einzelnen Entscheidung, die sie treffen, ihren Astrologen und rufen bei Astro-TV an. Geben da wahnsinnig viel Geld für aus und die machen sich wirklich abhängig von solchen Glaubensmodellen. Und die Amtskirchen vertreten keine Positionen, mit denen ich persönlich irgendwie nicht leben kann.
Die sagen ja auch, die Schöpfung der Welt in sieben Tagen, das ist halt nicht so Tage, wie wir uns die Tage vorstellen und so. Irgendwie so die Reihenfolge kommt ja so ein bisschen hin, was dann wann wie sich entwickelt hat und die können da wunderbar mit beidem leben.
Das heißt auch da kann sich sagen wir mal ein entspannterer Ansatz durchsetzen, dass man sozusagen … ich meine wir hatten ja auch ganz andere Zeiten, wenn wir mal ein paar hundert Jahre zurückschaut, wo halt Wissenschaftler wie Galilei etc. ja nun schwer zu leiden hatten unter den religiösen Kreisen, das ist sozusagen überwunden. Das Kernproblem ist jetzt woanders.
Also ich sehe es überwunden. Das ist in den USA was komplett anderes. Da ist es ja richtig, da hat die Kirche so einen massiven Einfluss und es sind einfach so viel mehr Leute, die so evangelikalen Kirchen angehören oder anhängen. Ich glaube, das ist bei uns wirklich überschaubar der Einfluss der Kirchen.
Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Mit der Gesellschaft.
Ja was müssen wir mit der Gesellschaft machen. Genau also in den USA ist es ja so, dass die wirklich auch einen massiven Einfluss haben auf das, was an den Schulen gelehrt wird. Dann gab es ja diese Diskussion vor längerer Zeit über dieses Intelligent Design, dass es als sozusagen eine göttliche Schöpfung sozusagen als gleichberechtigt im Biologieunterricht neben der Evolutionslehre unterrichtet werden sollte. Das haben wir ja nie ansatzweise hier gehabt. Das war allerdings für mich damals, als die damalige hessische Kultusministerin gesagt hat, ja man könnte mal drüber nachdenken, ob wir Intelligent Design auch mit ins Curriculum der Biologie aufnehmen. Das war für mich der Anstoß, in die GWUP einzutreten. Weil ich gedacht habe, so jetzt müssen wir uns wirklich dagegen formieren. Das kommt schleichend. Ich meine da redet heute kein Mensch mehr von. Es hat dann insofern sehr gut geklappt, da hat die Vernunft gesiegt.
Aber in den USA  ist es so, ich habe mit amerikanischen Freunden gesprochen, die sagen, die haben keinen Sexualkundeunterricht an der Schule, weil die Kirche sagt, die wollen das nicht. Weil die Kirche sagt, da haben die Kinder schon mit 13 Sex, wenn wir denen erzählen wie es geht. Auch total bekloppt. Und er sagt ja mit dem Erfolg, dass die Leute nicht wissen, dass man vom Sex schwanger werden kann und nicht wissen, dass man davon Krankheiten bekommen kann und wie man beides verhindert, das lernen die einfach nicht. Und das ist ein total großes Risiko, dem unserer Jugendlichen ausgesetzt sind, weil die Kirchen so viel Einfluss haben.
Tja.
Was wollen wir tun? Wie geht es weiter? Ja Mund aufmachen. sich äußern und auch gerne mal … also der Freundeskreis wird kleiner, wenn man ständig laut sagt, dass man Homöopathie total blöd findet. Und ich glaube, woran man auch gut tut ist, halt nicht immer nur so drauf zu dreschen und zu sagen, ihr spinnt doch, wie könnt ihr denn daran glauben? Ihr habt doch studiert, das kann doch nicht sein, dass du allen Ernstes denkst, dass so Zuckerkügelchen helfen oder dass es hilft dir einen Kristall auf den Schreibtisch zu legen oder deinem Kind einen Kristall auf den Schreibtisch zu legen, damit es sich bei den Hausaufgaben besser konzentrieren kann, das habe ich auch schon gesehen. Sondern es hilft auch, sich mal damit auseinanderzusetzen, da gibt es auch ein paar gute Bücher dazu, wie es eigentlich funktioniert, dass man Leute überzeugt.
Und dass man zum Beispiel lieber erst mal fragt und sagt, wieso glaubst du denn daran? Was glaubst du denn, wie das funktioniert? Und denen sozusagen sie selbst auf die Schwächen der Theorien kommen lässt. Das bringt mehr, wenn es darum geht, Leute zum Nachdenken anzuregen, als zu sagen, ihr spinnt doch alle, ihr habt keine Ahnung. Wei dann bilden die so einen Schutzpanzer um sich rum und werden trotzig.
Wie macht man das? Wie geht man da ran?
Ja zum Beispiel indem man sagt, weißt du wie das hergestellt wird? Hast du dich da mal mit auseinandergesetzt, wie das gemacht wird? Wie ist denn der Mechanismus dahinter. Und wäre es nicht so, wenn das jetzt funktioniert, was du glaubst, müsste dann nicht das und das auch funktionieren? Also um das nochmal am Beispiel der Homöopathie zu machen. Ich meine diese Wassermoleküle, mit denen das verdünnt wird, die haben halt schon alles mögliche gesehen, da ist alles mögliche drin verdünnt. Alles was bei uns im Ozean oder in den Kläranlagen rumschwimmt. Und zu sagen, warum ist denn genau dieses eine Molekül hat sich dem Wasser als Erinnerung eingeprägt? Und warum nicht die ganzen anderen Moleküle, mit denen es in Kontakt war? Wenn man so was sagt und halt nicht allzu offensiv vorgeht, hat man mehr Erfolg. Also es gibt auch Studien dazu, die sagen, dass man dann mehr Erfolg hat.
Erfolg im Sinne von messbaren Konvertiten, die dann sozusagen auch von diesem Glauben wieder abgesprungen sind?
Ja. Genau, gibt es ein paar. Man darf halt nur nicht sagen, wie kannst du so ein Idiot sein, dass du daran glaubst? Weil wenn man mir so was sagen würde, würde ich mich halt auch immer mehr vertiefen, einigeln und ich würde sozusagen dieser Bestätigungseffekt, ich würde nach den Sachen googeln, nach den Sätzen, die das bestätigen, was ich eh schon denke und würde da hunderte von Seiten finden, die das bestätigen. Das kann man auch Leuten beibringen, zu sagen, wie musst du eine Google-Anfrage stellen, damit du eine Chance hast, auch Sachen zu finden, die deiner vorgefertigten Meinung widersprechen. Wie kann man das und wie könntest du suchen und was würde dann passieren? Dass man sich so was erst mal klarmacht, diese psychologischen Effekte.
Und ich glaube, wir als Wissenschaftler müssen auch sagen, erstmal anerkennen, dass man als Menschen in verschiedenen bestimmten Denkmustern denkt, oder dass es sehr verlockend ist, bestimmte Kausalitäten zum Beispiel herzustellen. Und dass es anstrengend ist, das loszulassen, weil uns einfach auch die Evolution dazu gemacht hat. Zu sagen, wenn A passiert und dann wenn mir eine schwarze Katze über den Weg läuft und an dem Tag passiert irgendwas schlechtes, dann verknüpfe ich so was halt sehr schnell, weil die Evolution mich dazu gemacht hat. Und anzuerkennen, dass es anstrengend ist, den Leuten auch zu sagen, dass es anstrengend ist, kritisch zu denken. Und dann aber gleichzeitig auch das ernst zu nehmen, was Menschen für Ängste mitbringen. Oder so Verständnis dem entgegen zu bringen.
Dass Leute lieber so handeln, wie es für sie am einfachsten und am besten ist und für sie irgendwie plausibel klingt. Und nicht die Leute so hinzustellen, dass sie zu faul sind richtig nachzudenken. Das machen wir ja auch. Ich meine, das macht ja jeder von uns. Also jeder von uns, ach ja bei den Skeptikern ist es so, wenn man da auf so einer Konferenz ist, da würde jeder sagen, nein Medizin nur evidenzbasiert. Natürlich ich würde nie irgendwas machen, was nicht evidenzbasiert ist und dann guckst du dir die Leute an und was meinst wie viele von denen echt zu viel Gewicht mit sich rumschleppen. Also solche Bäuche da haben, wo du denkst, evidenzbasiert, das ist 1A evidenzbasiert, dass Sport und gesunde Ernährung gut für dich ist. Genau und die Leute sitzen trotzdem lieber im Internet und essen dazu Pizza.
Ja weil es halt einfach menschlich ist. Sich das auch klarzumachen, dass es nicht einfach ist, sich von morgens bis abends rational zu verhalten.
Ja jetzt haben wir hier ein schönes Spektrum abgegrast von zwei Dingen, die vielleicht auf den ersten Blick erst mal nichts miteinander zu tun haben, aber ich finde trotzdem dann doch miteinander zu tun haben. Auf der einen Seite Wissenschaft sich mal neu, anders, lebhafter kommunizieren zu lassen, indem man einfach eben auch die Prozesse zugänglich macht und eben Wissenschaft nicht immer nur so vom Ergebnis her definiert. Auf der anderen Seite, dass man auch merkt, mit dem Spaß und dem Wissen kommt auch eine gewisse Verantwortung, die man nicht nur jetzt in Verachtung für weniger erleuchtete Menschen zum Ausdruck bringen kann, sondern man muss sich im Prinzip da auch genauso Mühe geben, alles zu erläutern. Den Leuten einfach auch einen Weg zu ebnen, sich sozusagen der wissenschaftlichen Methode aus zu nähern und mit ihr auch warm zu werden.
Ich glaube das ist oft so ein bisschen das Problem und das wird dann auch leicht ausgenutzt von Leuten, die daran ein Interesse haben, das ganze also so eine kalte Gestalt hinzustellen. Ja die Wissenschaft, die irgendwie da in ihren Elfenbeintürmen hochbezahlt vor sich hin mäandern und davon habe ich ja eigentlich gar nichts. Wahrscheinlich ist das am Ende einfach nötig, überhaupt sozusagen die Erzählung der Wissenschaft ein bisschen neu abzurunden. Inwiefern könnte man denn solche neuen Maßnahmen, solche Kommunikationsmaßnahmen Teil der Ausbildung werden lassen? Oder geht das überhaupt?
Naja man könnte das erstmal mehr wertschätzen. Also ich habe ja noch vor der Bologna-Reform studiert, aber die kriegen ja für alles mögliche jetzt ihre Creditpoints und auch für so nicht fachliche Kompetenzen. Sie können ja auch irgendwie lernen, wie man wissenschaftlich schreibt und so was, was bei uns irgendwie nicht angeboten wurde seinerzeit. Da könnte man auch sagen, Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, Outreach, mal wohin zu gehen. Oder sich zu beteiligen, Konzepte zu schreiben für so einen Tag der offenen Tür oder lange Nacht der Wissenschaften. Da gibt es ja viel. Oder mal hier bei der Kinderuni, es gibt ja viele solche Maßnahmen, da zu sagen, hey ich finde das super, wenn du deine Doktorarbeit jetzt mal ein paar Tage hinten anstellst und dich darauf ordentlich vorbereitest, damit die Leute verstehen, was wir hier machen. Wenn das so die Doktorväter und -mütter sagen würden, das wäre glaube ich ein erster wichtiger Schritt.
Ich glaube von den jüngeren Wissenschaftlern haben das viele gemerkt, dass das auch wichtig ist, aber man muss sie dazu noch mehr ermutigen und man muss sie da auch irgendwie für belohnen in Form von was weiß ich, diesen Creditpoints, die es jetzt heutzutage gibt.
Oder einem Preis auf einem Science-Slam.
Oder einem Preis auf dem Science-Slam, ja das kriegen die ja, aber die Unis selbst, der akademische Betrieb selbst müsse das mehr belohnen und mehr wertschätzen. Das wäre glaube ich gut.
Und sozusagen die Studenten auch ermuntern, auf den Science-Slam zu gehen.
Ja auf den Science-Slam zu gehen oder auch zu bloggen oder einen Podcast zu machen oder auch bei Blogs nur zu kommentieren, das ist ja auch schon was. Einfach zu sagen, hier wir sind da und es gibt viele Leute und das ist jetzt nicht ein einzelner Blogger, der der Meinung ist, sondern es gibt ganz viele. Es gibt eine wunderbare Maßnahme wieder aus den USA, da haben die Kreationisten gesagt, wir haben 100 Professoren für Biologie, die sagen, Intelligent Design ist richtig, die Evolutionstheorie ist falsch. Dann hat eine amerikanische Evolutionsbiologin, Eugene Scott hat gesagt, okay. Ich sage es gibt 1000 amerikanische Biologieprofessoren, die Steve heißen und sagen, sie ist richtig. Und sie hat sie auch zusammen bekommen. Einen dieser Steves habe ich kennengelernt, der hat mir das erzählt.
Und so dann zu sagen, wir lassen nicht einfach machen, sondern wir halten jetzt gegen und sagen, wir sind viele und 100 ist keine Zahl. Und so was müsste man einfach mehr machen, zu sagen, ich nehme mir jetzt die Zeit dafür, weil es ist wichtig, dass wir so wahrgenommen werden und nciht nur die Spinner wahrgenommen werden.
Und man kann ja auch Spaß dabei haben?
Ja man kann jede Menge Spaß dabei haben.
Bis hin zur Selbstständigkeit mit dem Spaß.
Ja.
Julia Offer vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zu Spaß und Skepsis in der Wissenschaft.
Vielen Dank auch.
Und vielen Dank auch natürlich auch wieder hier fürs Zuhören bei Forschergeist. Bis bald.